Did you not scoff when the Lancet thing came out? >> You
just you guys casually accuse people of like wanting Palestinian
people to suffer. It's disgusting.
>> It is disgusting what you guys do. >> It's your
willingness to ignore statistics when it's when it's not uh uh
helpful for you. >> I have never He's basically, you know,
this is like third grade stuff you learn in the in the schoolyard.
Hey, can can we be friends? Can we Well, I know we weren't friends,
but like how do we be friends now? That's actually true. Let's
give that point to Hutch. They weren't randomly targeting civilian
buildings. They were intentionally targeting civilian buildings.
But how did he go to clout sharking? Who's talking about clout
sharking? >> Me to give up. What am I? >> The answer
is nothing. They've decided you guys are lepers. That's what
they've done. They want to convince everybody that you're lepers
that you're better left behind. >> Demanding first of all.
>> Probably get on to some content here. Give me a second.
You know what? Let's do the hutch stuff right off the bat. Why
not? One second. One second. Hold on. I'm just going to try to
tell uh what do you call it? Oh, it's not a big deal. Never mind.
Uh Space Ghost, if you're watching, if you're listening right
now, just keep on the uh keep doing the one you were doing, the
July 20th. That's fine. Thank you. I was working on the July
19th one cuz I didn't do an extra. I just missed a day, but it's
fine. I only put like one thing in there and we've already covered
it so it's not a big deal. Are people at kick actual paid him
all that money and Destiny could still stream to YouTube? God
damn. Um, yeah, cuz he put what the kickot on the on the screen.
There were some other things. Yeah. Is Hutch really going to
debate Queen? Apparently tomorrow. Yeah, apparently tomorrow.
That'll be exciting. I don't know what they're debating on. Apparently
Hutch was going to watch his content today. Do you think Hutch
did watch his content today? I'm like trying to think. He had
to do some Well, no. The kick exclusive streams was like it was
kick or keep that he didn't even run. He just sat in the corner
and answered emails. They got pretty They got pretty jacked up
in that contract. I'm not going to lie. They got pretty in that
contract. I think tourniquet, you're probably not wrong that
the Destiny investment was better than a lot of their other ones,
but I think it still was not like an effective use of money.
The thing with kick though is they don't have to make effective
uses of money, right? Like they they literally have all the money
in the world and some of it is like I wouldn't call it um
it's not like questionable. It's just like they've got a lot
of money to burn and just putting it into stuff like like paying
for, you know, to land and expand it. It'd make perfect sense
for them. They're one of the few people or few companies in the
world that don't have like a giga revenue stream right now. H
tournic. I very much doubt that. The data is pretty in on how
much panel shows actually help small streamers. It's basically
none. It's basically nothing at all. I would point out to you
that Darius was on those those panels multiple times. I don't
think he built any audience off of those panels. Um, it was when
he started doing his own content that was interesting in its
own way by him getting arrested. It seems like uh that's when
his started to take off. No, I don't think he was terrible at
consistent stream. I mean, he probably was. He tends to always
be terrible at consistent streaming, but uh
I just say there I don't think anybody joined those panels who
had a major like take off in their in their panel shows just
don't do that. Panel shows can be nice and they're good for your
own content, but unless they're like unless they're content you
thrive in, they they don't work for you, right? Like unless you're
farming clips for yourself, they don't really work for you. That's
how you have to look at panel shows.
There's like every there's a ton of evidence that panel shows
just don't really help the participants if the participants aren't
like farming clips off of them anyway. And by a ton of evidence,
I mean a little bit of evidence from the only person I've ever
seen make a video on it. Like I would say, isn't Wes like the
best example? Wes is like killer on every panel show and he doesn't
get like massive viewership, right? But he's he's totally killer
on all of those shows. No, but Wes does not get a big viewership
off of off of doing those. Like, he doesn't get massive increases
in viewership. And he is funny and he's a great performer on
those shows. So, it's a little crazy to me that he doesn't really
get the bump at all. Okay, hold on. I'm going to go to this uh
this Hutch. Where do we got it? Where do we got it? Uh, let's
see here. I think there's a Cherry tweet about it. Is this Hutch
ogre boy? >> This is me coming to the table. This is >> Hold
on. Caller Hutch, what do you think? Well, a Connor boy would
say, "Oh, no. >> You have my solemn attention right now.
I'm letting you set terms. I want to know from you. Okay.
>> What does any other leftist out there, what do they
have to gain from coalition building with Hutch? And what is
Hutch willing to give up as part of building that coalition?
>> Well, if you ask Econo Boy who just came out as a socialist,
he would tell you that you should vote for a Democrat because
the Republican uh whenever they win, it leads to worse outcomes.
That's what he would say. >> You have my solemn attention
right now. I'm letting you set terms. I want to know from you.
Okay. We don't care about
>> What does any other leftist out there, what do they
have to gain from coalition building with Hutch? And what is
Hutch? >> Oh, whoops. Jesus. I didn't realize how short
that was. That's my bad. More context, longer clip. Caller is
asking Hutch what leftists get out of coalition building with
him. H I do want to watch >> Coming to the table. >> My
answer is a firm
>> no. I don't want you in my coalition.
>> You have my solemn attention right now. I'm letting
you set terms. My answer is >> I want to know from you.
Okay.
>> What does any other leftist out there, what do they
have to gain from coalition building with Hutch? And what is
Hutch willing to give up as part of building that coalition?
>> Well, if you ask Econo Boy who just came out as a socialist,
he would tell you that you should vote for >> just came
out as a socialist. I think that's at the first time. A Connor
Boy's parents, they're very conservative. They've never been
more embarrassed. They actually kicked him out of the house.
They denounced him. Okay. He came out as a socialist >> Democrat
because the Republican
uh whenever they win it leads to worse outcomes. That's what
he would say and he's correct. >> No, no, no. That I'm
asking you. What are you willing to get on board with change
about your uh asks and demands and things of that nature? And
then what would you expect me to give up? What am >> The
answer is nothing. They've decided you guys are lepers. That's
what they've done. They want to convince everybody that you're
lepers that you're better left behind. >> Demanding first
of all, what demands have I ever made? Hey, Ogre Boy is awesome.
Okay, we love we love Ogre Boy in this house. Ogre Boy may be
like cringe sometimes, but hey, we love Ogre Boy in this house.
Okay, he will come and fight. He will come and fight on stream
about like whatever he believes. All right, which is more than
we could say for a lot of people who just won't do it ever. >> I'm
asking the question. I don't care about demands. I I want to
get away from demands. That's my point. >> So, you expect
nothing from me and I shouldn't expect anything from you? I don't
want anything from you. Do you understand that? I don't want
you in the coalition. I think you're bad for the
>> A lefty, you're trying to dradicalize leftists by coalition
building, right?
>> Yes. Yes. >> Okay. So, in that coalition, >> there's
supposed to be some element, some tiny element of like, hey,
I will lend support for this. I will start doing this and in
turn, I would like it if you would do that.
>> I already told you what I would do. I am willing to
support any Democratic candidate who becomes the nominee. I'm
willing to throw my support whatever
>> Well, Sidonia, the funny thing here is what their what
their cringe or sorry, what their criticism of leftists is is
that they purity test people out of the coalition, right? Give
me my Hassan is bads. Han is bad. How many did you do? Hold on.
I don't have my kick dashboard up. Assad. Oh, it's just one.
Okay. Well, there you go. Damn.
So, they'll they'll purity test people out of the coalition.
Leftist. That's what makes them bad. And what do we have to do?
How do we answer that? We purity test them out of the coalition.
You can't make it up. You actually can't make it up. That is
legitimately I'm not even trying to like malign somebody or make
anything up here. That is like actually that is actually what
their rationale is. If they're not interested in a coalition
with libs, dude. Well, not internet leftist, but I'm sure a lot
of real life leftists would be. And here's Ogre Boy, an actual
internet leftist who is saying, "Hey, Hutch, I want to build
a coalition with you. What would you need from me? What can I
what can you give me? Okay. What what can you what can I give
you? What can you give me? I want to build a coalition. Can we
talk about this theoretically? >> That means with my modest
platform, I will endorse a socialist over a fascist every time.
Would you endorse a liberal over a fascist every time? >> I
was telling people to vote for Kla prior to the election. >> No,
no, no. But moving forward, I'm saying like just as a rule of
thumb, are you down with blue no matter who? I was telling people
prior to this last election to that they should vote. >> That's
not my question. Are you down with blue no matter who?
>> Not if it's like a Bloomberg. >> Okay. So that's
why I don't want you in this coalition because you're worthless.
Because you're worthless to this coalition. You You're not This
isn't reciprocal.
You understand? What are you contributing to my coalition?
Nothing. You just you're you're on a you have a partisan ideological
agenda. That's it.
So if somebody runs if if a Republican turns around tomorrow
says they're a Democrat and that they want to run as a Democrat
with no change whatsoever in their policies, their their outlook,
how they treat vulnerable minority groups, how they treat LGBTQ,
they change nothing. They just say, "I'm a Democrat. I'm supposed
to get on board."
>> All right. Stop watching clips. I was just Yeah, I started
watching the clip. Listen, I was I was riveted. Okay, we can
skip past that. I don't know if they debate for much longer.
They must cuz dude the reaction dude I don't know how to explain
this the reaction you have a partisan agenda without a shred
of irony hutch really >> I know I know
I dude it's it's a little wild okay all right
we got my hutch stuff
3 hours into
>> what are we doing >> I think they said something
to the effect of we want our next Democratic president to do
what Trump does and just basically whip the out of his advance
your particular when he gets when he gets back. >> Right
here. Right here. Right here. Right here.
>> What are we doing? What are we doing? We're getting
in here. >> Is he ready? Hold on. >> Okay. So, he's
going to do this with ochre boy. Give me two seconds. I just
need to get more water. I always I sit down for stream and then
I drink both the drinks. I get I get like a pop and I get a full
water and then I drink both and then it's like 30 minutes into
Bro, I don't know how how
nothing. We're gonna cover this. All right. Water. Yeah, it is.
It's literally water and pop. I get like a a pop with some ice
and then I get water and I drink both and then I have to go to
the bathroom. So, Pepsi Max. Yes. Well, we call it Pepsi Zero
Sugar in Canada, but it Pepsi Max. Is Jtock bald? No. Although
I did reveal recently a little bit that my barber for the first
time ever told me he was like hey just so you know you're thinning
a little bit on top and I was like you you I'm never coming back
to this establishment again ever
Yeah. So there's that. Okay. There is that. No barber should
say I guess he was trying to help me out. He was like you're
thinning a little bit on top. I was like you piece of [__]
How dare you? How dare you? Time for a finaster ride. Well, I
wear long I wear my hair long, so I probably should though, right?
Shouldn't everybody start that as soon as they possibly can?
But like I don't have any history of um of baldness on either
side of my family. So, I'm like not that worried about it. But
then I Yeah, embrace the Finny Rage like Chud maybe.
Okay. All right. I'm going to hit I'm going to play on this.
I'm going to get a drink. I will be right back. I'll be right
back.
There is a tremendous delay on YouTube.
>> Huh? Oh, >> messaging like is he I thought he's
still in the bathroom. Like it's it's a decent delay. >> Yeah,
YouTube. There's a delay that's more than Twitch.
>> Uh, okay. Let's get into it, buddy. I see you've been
um tweeting about me
Oh, I I talk my I talk my >> You said recently that you
feel bad for me and that like by debating me it would be punching
down. What do you mean by >> You were on a really wild
tear on Friday. No. >> Which tear? >> You don't uh
towards the end of this the thing that I screenshotted that that
got your attention in the first place. >> I don't even
put up the uh >> I don't I don't even remember.
>> I mean that kind of speaks to it. Don't you think? The
Twitter video towards the end. What's the uh Sarah what Sarah
McBride? What's what's her name? >> Sarah Mc Yeah. Rep.
Sarah McBride. Yeah. >> Right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> So,
you couldn't make it through the video. You kept resetting it
several times and in the course of which you were talking on
and on about uh how you would donate to Liz Cheney and you missed
the point of of her video altogether with what she was trying
to say. You >> No, it sounds like you No, no, no, no. It
sounds like you did, by the way. >> Enlighten me >> because
the point of her video was that the way the Democrats are going
to win is through coalition building, but it cuts both ways.
>> Okay. You understand?
>> You you understand that >> coalition building,
guys. It's time to build a coalition, guys. >> Specifically
talking about how there was a need to remember that there were
left-leaning people in the party that need we need to remember
that and make sure we still make space for them as >> And
the
face was, guys, guys, you moderate Republicans. >> And
I agreed. Do you understand that? Like my my principal position
on coalition building is that it necessarily cuts both ways.
And so when I see Democrats that are sort of hedging against
Mumani right now, I think that's a problem. And similarly, when
I hear rhetoric from lefties, leftists, fringe leftists is what
we decided. When I hear rhetoric from them saying that they want
to push people out of the party because they're more moderate
than them, that's also bad. You understand that? That's like
a principled position that I have. >> I feel like it's
a little I feel like the way that you present that is a bit more
vague than it actually is, but >> Enlighten me.
Uh I because you use a lot of things that that at surface level
sound great that we should be inclusive and and everything when
you get into it there's there's certain things that you just
leave out like you never mentioned like what does it mean to
uh form a coalition essentially right >> what do you think
what do you think what do you >> is this just going to
be him asking the same questions back >> what is that what
it's going to be the whole time >> elaborate the question
a little bit better okay so in essence right And you keep you
keep directly sort of saying that you want to form a coalition
with this person and this person, etc. >> Why do we have
the owl head movements going on? Do you see this? Am I am I the
only one seeing this? That Hutch is like an owl right now. This
>> is weird. It just comes across as like a
>> Hold on. You'll see it. Hold on. Hold on. Dude, I I
don't know what's going on. Hold on. I want the Can we Can we
see this? Can I see this? Oh, it's like uh You ever see the p
the video of like the baby owls? Baby owl's gift. Well, they're
like looking around. Oh, I can't even I can't find anything.
That's exactly what I'm looking for. It's fine. >> And
you keep you keep drawing creepy back and you want to form a
coalition with this person and this person, etc.
>> Yeah, he just did a line. Okay. >> Cross is like
a desire to do >> Hutch just absolutely,
>> you know, sorted a couple rails. Okay. He is ready to
go. He's locked the in >> like networking or collabing
in that regard. Uh
what
what's when you talk when you talk about you talk come on come
on come on come on when you have people on speed dial like um
what was that conservative dude that Pisco used to argue with
all the time and that you would cut videos with as well
is ogre boy talking about his content
>> Rob no like when you guys when you guys have people
like that in your speed that your rolodex right it's so that
you can make videos where you argue with each other and then
you both cut a video on it and you both like it It's what you
do for a living. It's not necessarily because you're trying to
accomplish some sort of political goal or the same thing with
with Connor points or whatever. It's not necessarily because
you guys are trying to further a political goal per se. It's
also because you're trying to further your own like uh networking
brand. Look at look how I dominated this conservative in the
marketplace of ideas. And then they end up saying the exact same
thing. >> You think I'm clout sharking Rob
No. >> No. No. No. No. No. No. No. >> Well, how did
he go to cloud sharking? Who's talking about clout sharking?
The [__] are we doing?
Hold on. I should put accurate things in my titles. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. There we go. >> No, not cloud.
>> Why does it have to be He's literally He's like, "Isn't
it nice when you can talk to people on the other side and do
content with them? Are you saying I cloud shark rob networking
that is more performative than anything else?" Cloud sharking
would be going after a bigger figure and and uh trying to either
rub elbows with or show that you can uh win in an argument or
whatever for sake of like look who I just dominated. >> I'm
saying you guys keep
>> I was totally in on Ogre Boy's side, but that voice
crack
>> we're we're Hutch cells now. Okay. Unfortunately, we
got to go to Hutch's side. Ogre Boy's voice cracked. That's an
auto loss.
of people that are probably never going to align with you ideologically
or never help actually try to advance your particular agenda,
but in turn the fact that you have >> this was what I was
talking about. Yes, this video of like the side to side owl.
You can like watch it like go like this and go back. It was like
something like this. Yeah, it's like
it's always a creep with a decent enough following to make videos
about is going to be something that that helps you in the long
run just as much as them. It's mutually beneficial, but it helps
nobody in the end at the end of the day. >> You know, I
I feel like I'm punching down right now. Like, you're not on
my >> I Okay, >> straight up. Do you understand that?
Because I could see that platform because because
>> based on what? You haven't even had a conversation yet.
What is this based on? >> In the long run, just as much
as them, it's mutually beneficial, but it helps nobody in the
at the end of the day. >> You know, I I feel like I'm punching
down right now. Like, you're not on my >> I Okay, >> straight
up. Do you understand that? Because I could see the platform
because
>> honestly I was going to I was going to going to do something
a bit of a chud logic here. Okay. And message queen and be like
maybe don't touch. But you know what it
is a bold that's that's cringe. I don't know why why the would
you do >> because no no intellectually because uh what
every everything that you just said I can apply to this conversation.
You know you're not going to change my mind. So, why are you
having a conversation with me? It's stupid. Do you understand
>> I think if I wanted to steal my ogre boy, it's probably
like, well, actually, when you make content with somebody on
the other side, one, the the actual beefs are real. It's not
people like act talking in hypotheticals. You people who really
believe they're like whatever they're arguing for and it makes
better content. You can actually you can actually see like the
political schism when you have a conservative and an actual liberal
or leftist talking because they will actually dislike each other
and they'll talk and it'll turn into content and probably everybody
benefits from hearing both sides of the argument represented
in good faith. So the notion that I have to necessarily change
your mind applies in the exact same way as people with mutually
sized audiences that you keep around for the purposes of just
cutting videos. >> You said one of the problems with me
having conversations with Rob Noir was that I was never going
to change his >> No, no, no. Not >> that's what you
said. >> That you keep him on a rolodex that you keep this
network of people just for the purposes of making content and
that you know ultimately it never goes anywhere. >> Oh,
I see. No, no, no. I see what he's saying. I see what he's saying.
He's going to roll this into like a a total criticism of like
why is Hassan so bad when you know like Hassan can help you?
Hassan can be like like you're willing to talk to conservative
over time, right? You're willing to go hook up with talk to Rob
No, right? No, no, no. I don't think I think the argument here,
Spriggs, is going to be something along these lines. Why the
I haven't watched forward, but we did watch that little clip.
Why the would you talk to Rob Nor? You're totally fine with doing
that even though you know you're not going to change his mind.
It's just for content. you're helping each other out. But like
Hassan is sacrilege. Hassan is evil. Why is that the case? Because
Ogre Boy is a massive Hassan fan. He's gonna He might say leftist,
but he'll mean Hassan. Okay. >> Content is a big part of
what I do. You understand that? Like I'm a content creator for
a living. That's what I said. So what's the problem with that?
>> Oh god. >> That is more performative than anything
else. That's the way it comes across. >> All of this is
performative. What do you think this is? It's a live stream.
Yeah.
What do you what when you keep doing the same things over and
over again with certain people that that it just turns to where
it's like, okay, we've squeezed the juice out of this to the
fullest extent that we possibly could and that ultimately it's
not really going to end up going anywhere. >> So, this
is not >> you still do it over and over again. >> So,
this conversation that we're having right now is not performative.
>> Not really. >> It's not. What do you mean? You're
not going to change my mind? >> No, this is this is purely
katharsis. Oh, so you're just chasing catharsis.
>> Yeah. Being able to basically tell someone to their
face that they're wrong for the And and for no real like self-enrichment,
I'm not going to get anything out of this. >> No real self
no real self-enrichment. What do you mean? You're you're live
streaming right now. You're going to try to get your little like
Twitter videos that get like likes with you shouting into the
void. >> You don't think And you don't think it serves
your own like ego purposes yourself? think I cut you're doing
all this altruistically. >> I'm making vid you think I'm
making videos for like you think I've been cut like I've done
one Tik Tok and it was to on Dan Saltman and it went nowhere
and ever since then I haven't touched a damn thing about it.
I don't make videos of >> Why do you post videos online?
>> There's a lot of the formulaic things that I don't do
that one should do if they're trying to grow their brand. This
is just a hobby for me. >> Okay, let's talk about AOC.
Why don't we do that? >> I don't Dude, that conversation
was ass. Well, why don't we finish the I mean you
>> what would be the point of building a coalition with
Hassan again? Hassan will always take his ball and go home the
moment things don't go his way. Hassan has proven that. I would
say more with leftist than Hassan specifically. But the idea
is that like if you want to just write off people entirely or
if you sorry if you want to argue that people shouldn't get written
off entirely for like one belief or you want to say that like
hey we have to you know pull together we should we can't cut
people out because of how they act in certain cases how they're
like inflammatory or something and they pick people off. Well,
you should probably be able to apply that to Hassan as well and
not like explicitly try to push him away. That's all. So >> you
don't you don't have to you don't have to coalition build with
um with Assad. It's just that like probably if you're going to
say, "Well, we should coalition build with the center." And but
those leftists, they purity test people, so we have to we have
to get them out of our movement entirely. It's like, okay, but
they they purity test. Sorry, that's a purity test. >> Boring.
It's so stupid that it's so boring. Your argument is so stupid
that it's so boring. >> Started having the argument. >> I
don't care about it. This is nonsense. You Everything you've
said so far is ridiculous. said you you trying to make you you
taking someone's like relatively uh bold thing where they've
been saying hey we've >> really ogre boy that's the pot
calling the pet kettle black if I've ever seen it a relatively
bold thing
really was that necessary I think >> someone's like relatively
uh bold thing where they've been saying hey we've been spending
a lot of time trying to figure out how to bring in conservatives
and we have to remember leftists too and then you got clapback
back from your audience when they said, "Come on, man." Right
after your first >> Did I say, "Dude,
>> the dementia is real. >> You know, there's conservative
Republicans we need to think about." >> I agree. I agreed
with her. >> You spent the >> What is your point?
>> Time trying to push back on that particular thing. You
>> because in my Twitch audience, >> remember leftists,
>> you used her remember leftist people in the conversation.
You use that as a fulcrum to to open. You open, you put your
foundational thing as, hey, there's Republicans, guys. Your own
audience push back on it. >> My own audience. I have like
>> I have like like a set number of leftist hate watchers
that push back against the things that I say in Twitch and I
engage with them. But I agreed with her point. Her point applies
in both directions. I am fully cons No, it What are you talking
about? I have always been consistent in this respect. Coalition
building is like my entire priority right now. That's all I'm
thinking about >> and it does go both ways. So, as soon
as mom as soon as we saw Democrats,
>> okay, well, he's Listen, maybe it's just >> hedging
against mom Donnie. I spoke up right away and I said blue no
matter who means like Mum Donnie and and >> except for
the fact that you've also for a while now you've been diving
through any piece of content you can find about him to try to
find ways to still pick it apart. You're still c I have no idea
what you're talking about, bro. You can ask anyone. No, you don't.
>> Ogre boy, do we have examples of this? Is there an example?
I don't like that that you just said he's doing this. And I would
want an example here. Okay. >> You can ask anyone in my
chat. >> I don't know if you're still here. >> I
would want an example. >> I said right away like I agree
with like 90% of this. There's a few policies that I don't like.
And then at every step of the way, he's been impressing me. >> What
did your mic just do? I move my mic down. My mic arm is loud.
>> Because he's doing coalition building, bro. He's in
DC trying to get the Jeff endorsement, man. He's trying to build
he's trying to build his tent, which already puts him in a totally
different category than all the other loser leftist progressive
candidates who don't even like who like nobody wants you to build
a coalition with Ilan. See, it's like somebody who also did this.
I would say probably you just you probably just look at them
and say on a case- by case basis, can I build a coalition with
you? Do you have some reasonability to you? But to say there's
no reason to throw up the big sign like, "Oh, leftist suck at
coalition building or something." You just don't have to do that.
Oh, is the mic still is there something with the mic?
Wait, is there something with the mic? Cable might be loose.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Is this better? Hello. Hello.
Hello. Hello. Randomly cutting out. Well, I don't want it to
be randomly cutting out, but is there something better now? Are
we better? Or is this better? I'm just reading. Your cable might
be loose. It cut out for like 2 seconds. Cutting out. It randomly
stops making noise, then starts again. You're going in and out.
JTO, you're good. Okay. Okay. >> Been tried a coalition
build. >> Okay. So, there's a couple very important things
about that. The first one is we don't know what the result of
that is going to end up being. We don't know what he's going
to willingly water down and what the people that got him through
the primary are going how they're going to respond to that in
in what he's willing to give up. >> He's going to the >> only
time will tell
positive or negative that that's going to end up being. >> He's
going to the general, bro. Like what do you think a primary candidates's
job is once they win the nomination? They every they're all going
to tell you the same thing. They want to grow their tent and
build a coalition
because most candidates can't win with just their
This is the part of politics that you guys completely miss. You
don't understand it at all.
So again, right, if >> I think that's probably a reasonable
a reasonable criticism of a lot of leftists is that they they
see stuff in the primary and they think that's the who the candidate's
going to be in the >> He goes and he ends up doing a lot
of the would make like Hakee Jeff and like that happy, content,
so that they finally endorse him, which I thought it was vote
blue no matter who, but that's beside the point. If he turns
around and waters down a lot of his policy proposals, his rhetoric,
everything across the board, do you not think that there's a
possibility there that he ends up alienating the energy that
that got him across the finish line in the primaries in the first
place? >> If he loses voters because he moderates his rhetoric
in a general election, those voters are too stupid to be saved.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Truly, they're too dumb to be saved.
So Ogre boy's question here should be, shouldn't there be some
consideration of this if you can only win a primary by lying
by saying, "Oh, I'm for these policies, right? And then you're
going to go into a general and like change what what policy planks
you're advocating for, right? Or platform planks you're advocating
for." If you have to do that, then shouldn't you just accurately
represent yourself in the >> These people are not serious.
These people are not serious people that message and then he
deters the people that put energy in him because he was his uh
uh message of trying to make their lives better and and uh talk
about the affordability of things. >> Do you think he's
going to give up on
cityrun
bedas because he had a conversation with Jeff? >> Time
will tell what the outcome of this >> No, but the very
concept alone offends you. The very concept of him shifting his
rhetoric
>> offends you. You're you're reaching. >> I'm not
I am not. Okay. How do you feel about time will tell? >> All right.
Well, how do you feel about him saying that globalized antifat
is >> I didn't hear. >> Ogre boy never thinks to
ask that because the person Ogre Boy is talking to is on Vance.
Okay. >> The exact quote. >> He said he said it was
bad. He said it was harmful. He said it was a harmful
>> Yes. How do you feel? How do you feel about that? >> I
can ar it I don't give a [__] one way or the other.
>> Yes, you do. Stop. You think that's
>> Stop. You're Now this is performative. Okay. cuz I know
that bugs you. I'm I would have >> a Bernie cut out behind
me that I've never gotten rid of. Like, if you want to start
talking about people that have disappointing elements of an overall
message, you're talking to the wrong >> Okay. How did How
did Bernie offend you? How did Bernie offend you? >> How
did Bernie offend you? >> Wait, what? >> Like, if
you want to start talking about people that have disappointing
elements of an overall message, you're talking to >> I'm
sure the This has got to be Bernie like showing support for Okay.
How did How did Bernie offend you? How did Bernie offend you?
>> Huh? How did Bernie offend you? >> I didn't say
offend. You You keep reaching for offense. >> How did he
disappoint you? How did he disappoint you? >> I think there's
elements where after this much time has passed and if you're
still clinging to uh uh rhetoric about right to defend itself
and things of that nature, I think is missing the >> What
Bernie said was that after October, he said this on Rogan, I
saw the clip. He said after October 7th, Israel obviously had
every right to retaliate against a barbaric act of terrorism
that amounted to war crimes. And then he went on to say, "But
but what they've done since that time has been too far and he
wants arms embargo and he wants >> Wait, can I ask Ogre
Boy now that you're in chat?" Okay, now that you're in chat,
can I ask you, did you see Hutch after did you get to watch him
after your debate? Cuz he kind of had like a a mini meltdown
after your debate that is probably funnier, way funnier in my
opinion than this actual debate itself.
I just got to know, did you did you actually keep watching? cuz
it's pretty good as >> he wants the violence to stop. >> he
even called it a genocide. He wants the genocide to stop. That
is like the only rational position to have. >> Do you disagree
that like >> better than most of Congress? What do you
mean? >> What was bad about what he said about >> By
virtue of the fact that you're still saying like right to retal
that's not even a retaliation if you're starting off bombing
civilians in the first >> What are you even What are you
talking about? retaliating by bombing civilians is like something
that we should be encouraging our like de uh democratic allies
in the Middle East to do. >> They were they bombed >> I
didn't actually get a chance to watch any of this debate. I tuned
in after the debate was done, but I just heard Hutch like hyperventilating
about the debate he' just been in and it was very >> after
October 7th, but they weren't like randomly targeting civilian
buildings.
>> Okay, whatever. Okay. >> Okay. But yeah, here's
the point.
That's actually true. Let's give that point to Hutch. They weren't
randomly targeting civilian buildings. They were intentionally
targeting civilian
So that is ogre boy kind of got owned there, okay? It wasn't
random. It was very intentional. >> I could send you links.
I could send you articles. We could get lost in the sauce from
this for days. And then as long as you're never willing to apply
any sort of criticality to >> Let's talk about AOC. Let's
talk about AOC. I don't I don't care about the Israel stuff.
Now, in fairness, they targeted civilian buildings that probably
were housing infrastructure and/or actual terrorists, at least
early on. I doubt they were, you know, murking civilians when
they had a lot of terrorists to actually at or a lot of like
infrastructure to actually ating
the topic >> cuz I don't care. We've already had this conversation.
I don't care. >> What did Bernie do to offend you? Well,
the Israel stuff. Uh, you know what? This is a stupid topic.
I don't care. Actually, let's move on. >> Let's I only
have 20 minutes. Let's talk about AOC. That's topical. It's
>> Topical re Well, we're still talking about mom, Donnie,
and Bernie. >> This is But this is all adjacent. This is
all related. You understand? We're We're diving into >> I
still want to ask you what I get out of building a coalition
with you. What are you willing to give up? >> I don't want
you in my coalition. I don't want you in my coalition. You understand
that? >> Because you're toxic. >> This is me. This
is me coming to the table. This is me coming to the table. >> My
answer. I can't think of anything more toxic to any political
movement than rational criticism of the state of Israel's actions
in Gaza post October 7th. Okay. This is the most dangerous thing
to any coalition in American >> No, I don't want you in
my coalition.
>> You have my solemn attention right now. I'm letting
you set terms. I want to know from you. Okay. >> I don't
care about
>> what does any other leftist out there, what do they
have to gain from coalition building with Hutch? And what is
Hutch willing to give up as part of building that coalition?
>> Well, if you ask Econoboy who just came out as a socialist,
he would tell you that you should vote for a Democrat because
the Republican uh whenever they win, it leads to worse outcomes.
That's what he would say. And he's correct. >> No, no,
no. That I'm asking you,
what are you willing to get on board with change about your uh
asks and demands and things of that nature? And then what would
you expect me to give up? >> What am I demanding? First
of all, what demands have I ever made? >> I'm asking the
question. Hutch Hutch's primary thing is coalition building,
by the way, guys. Okay. Hutch's primary thing is coalition building.
And he can't recognize when somebody's like, "Hey, I think we
should make like exceptions for each other's beliefs so we could
be in a coalition together. What would you want and what should
I want?" And he's like, "I don't want anything with you." You
>> question. Okay. All right. >> I don't care about
demands. I I want to get away from demands. That's my point.
So, you expect nothing from me and I shouldn't expect anything
from you. >> I don't want anything from you. Do you understand
that? I don't want you in the coalition. I think you're bad for
the
>> A lefty. You're trying to dradicalize leftists by coalition
building, right?
>> Yes. Yes. >> Okay. Yes. >> Okay. Okay. Okay.
We're reset. We're reset. We're reset. Okay. Okay. Now, Ogre
Boy's got them reset. It's going to be fine. I think it's going
to be fine. >> Coalition. There's supposed to be some element,
some tiny element of like, hey, I will lend support for this.
I will start doing this and in turn, I would like it if you would
do that. I >> I just want to make it clear. Ogre boy is
borderline asking like, hey, we didn't really like each other,
but I want to try to be friends. What could we be f like what
issue could we share that we could be friends on? Or what do
you what do you think you find most offensive about me that prevents
us from being friends? He's basically, you know, this is like
third grade stuff you learn in the in the schoolyard. Hey, can
can we be friends? Can we Well, I know we weren't friends, but
like how do we be friends now? >> Already told you what
I would do. I am willing to support any Democratic candidate
who becomes the nominee. I'm willing to throw my support, whatever
that means, with my modest platform. I will endorse a socialist
over a fascist every time. Would you endorse?
>> I will. Listen, I will I'll endorse you if it's Donald
Trump. >> A liberal over a fascist every time. >> What
is he? See, this is where you know he's totally lost. Okay, he's
like completely and entirely lost and just applying other labels
to this guy cuz everything every indicator in this conversation
is that Ogre boy is trying to be reasonable, trying to be like
nice and talk right the the fact that you'd ask this question
and and expect him to say no here is crazy. >> I was telling
people to vote for Kla prior to the election. >> No, no,
no, but moving forward. >> Yes, but okay, hold on. He's
okay. Well, he already gave you the concrete example and now
hypothetically moving forward, why would you expect him to say
no? >> Right. I'm saying like just as a rule of thumb,
are you down with blue no matter
>> I was telling people prior to this last election to
that they should vote. >> That's not my question. Are you
down with blue no matter? >> You shouldn't be down with
blue no matter who. But like against Trump, yeah, blue no matter
who makes sense, right? Blue no matter who. If you suddenly had,
let's say you have suddenly had um uh let's say Bernie Sanders
actually as the Democrat candidate and Joe Biden as the let's
10 years ago hypothetical matchup. Okay, Joe Biden is the Republican
candidate. You know what? It might not be blue no matter who
at that point. It might be actually I want Joe Biden cuz I I
think too far, you know, AOC is too far left. But in a hypothetical
like in a world where Trump exists, in a world where the Republicans
are where they are now, yeah, blue no matter who. >> No matter
who. Uh, not if it's like a Bloomberg or something. >> Okay.
So, that's why I don't want you in this coalition cuz you're
worthless. Because you're worthless to this coalition. You You're
not This isn't
>> So, Ogre Boy just gave the other example where it's
like, okay, like, you know, if it's Bloomberg versus Trump, then
I I don't know. I still think Ogre Boy, by the way, your answer
there should just be, yeah, if it's Bloomberg versus Trump, I
guess I'd vote Bloomberg. But like, it's stupid. Just so you
know, if you're trying to coalition build, okay, you kind of
did fail this question. Bloomberg versus Trump. Yeah. Okay.
If it's like Bloomberg versus Haley or if it's like, yeah, Haley
versus Kasich, Haley versus Cruz, it's like, yeah, okay. Like,
I I'm lost. I don't know where American politics is. That's fair.
You understand? What are you contributing to my coalition?
Nothing. You just you're you're on you have a partisan ideological
agenda. That's it. So if somebody runs if if a Republican turns
around tomorrow says they're a Democrat and that they want to
run as a Democrat with no change whatsoever in their policies,
their their outlook, how they treat vulnerable minority groups,
how they treat LGBTQ, they change nothing. They just say, "I'm
a Democrat. I'm supposed to get on board." Yes. Don't you think?
>> So you should It's important. You have to have both
sides defined here or you can't even answer the question against
Trump. I think Yeah. If if you if you could vote between Nikki
Haley and Trump, I hope you'd vote for Nikki Haley. Although,
actually, that could be the only the only candidate in history
who would be worse for Israel than Donald Trump is. >> That's
a little that that's a bit much, don't you think? >> Sorry.
Better for Israel than Donald Trump is. That's what I meant.
Better for Israel. >> No, I don't. You want me to explain?
>> No, it's it's just it's purely team >> You want
me to explain? >> Sure. If that Republican is the difference
between Democrats and Republicans uh or Democrats having the
majority or not, I'm going to support that candidate because
I want the >> I mean, it depends on what the It's gotten
too abstract now. You need to have more things defined here.
>> You understand? >> Okay. But what if it's a Democrat
that is ultimately trying to turn around and do grand bargains
left and right to sell away social safety net in order to secure
Republican votes? If that Democrat who was a win if that Democrat
who was very recently a repor
would be that it's probably a win because if it was like Trump
on the other side it's not just going to be social safety nets
that might get sold away. It might be like you're doing a bargain
but yeah it's like well we don't want people like black baby
we don't want the actual constitution like
undone right that those would be the arguments. Now, this is
a silly argument to engage in. It's like broadly within the current
parameters, blue no matter who is
>> Republican advances through the primary process and
that state or district's voters choose them and they're the only
Democrat running on that ticket and they're the only way to stop
Republicans from potentially getting majority in Congress, I'm
going to support that
>> in that hypothetical situation. >> Republicans
the way that um the ogre
>> then I would be disappointed. But your insane hypothetical
is so far removed. >> He's doing it now. >> Who?
What are you talking about? Give me one person who fits this
description. >> That wears shorts all the time. I can't
believe I'm blanking. >> Fedman. Fed >> Federman's
going to be a sore spot for these people. Federman is actually
the golem. Okay, I'll vote for Trump over the golem. Okay, at
least Trump's funny. >> Was not a registered No, he was
not a registered Republican. That Federman, by the way, is your
fault. For the record, that was the progressives that were heavily
pushing this guy. That's your That's on you. We could have had
Connor Lamb and you guys wanted him to be the guy. Okay. So now
he's the guy. That's your problem, bro. That's your problem,
>> I think he's talking about I think Federman had to deal
with a primary your hero before he got into that general, didn't
he? Didn't he? Wasn't there a primary there? >> Class people.
Okay, that's my problem. Should we kick John Fan out of the party?
Based on the way he's been, he should be primar into oblivion.
Yes. >> Would you sacrifice the dem uh congressional majority
to kick him out of the party? >> You have to start somewhere.
No. >> Would you? Yes or no? Would you sacrifice a majority?
>> So, as long >> Why don't you answer that question?
Yes, you would. >> Okay. That's why that's why I don't
want >> Answer should be no there. Okay. You have to you
have to adhere to game theory in some senses. uh the the total
like ignorance or refusal to accept math is a big reason people
don't want to coalition build with this right like hey um we
might be able to you know have some tangible
some tangible stuff some infrastructure spending maybe some you
know tax credits on certain social programs that could go out
for people right if we have you know a blue majority but I don't
want to do that cuz this one guy is like super [__]
on Israel like The hypotheticals won't come about, but you should
answer the right way, right? Why are you telling me this and
not Hutch? Well, ogre boy is in the chat. So, I'm I'm telling
Ogre Boy. I'm not telling you. I'm literally telling Ogre Boy.
You start somewhere and the stakes will always be too high to
course correct. Hutch doesn't think the ratchet effect is a real
thing. Yeah, it can be. But like the funny thing is is Hutch
doesn't think that's a real thing. But I think Pisco and Josiah
both think it's a real thing. So, I don't know, Ogre Boy, if
you watched the the post, was it the post convo after the debate
with the Vanguard people,
Hutch is explaining that like he doesn't think it's reasonable
to put pressure from the bully pulpit on on party members who
break from party lines. So, they argue that I don't know what
the ratchet effect is actually. I'd have to Google that, but
they I assume it's like putting pressure on like giving people,
you know, some negative downside to their behavior will prevent
them from engaging in it, right? Ratchet effect is the ratchet
effecti describes the tendency for things once improved or increased
to be to be difficult to reduce or decrease much like the mechanical
ratchet that only moves in one direction and economics or sociology.
So I see what you're saying. So basically as you as you move
people in the right direction on ideology
it's difficult for them to move back right in course of action
once a thing is oh and also if you let them in in the first place
it's hard to undo that. Sure. Sure. Sure. Um what what all I
would say is
is essentially like having some negative pressure on people for
like having lines basically for a voting block is probably essential
in getting politicians to bend to your will. So hey, we have
a red line absolutely on abortion or rifles. I think guns is
usually another big one in the US. If you if you made a voting
block that was on Israel, you could probably get some stuff done
in terms of um like having political capital in the US, right?
like if you're going to support Israel, you lose this entire
voting block. That's t that's how the most powerful voting coalitions
in the US work, right? The the the abortion people, the either,
you know, what do you call it? Like uh being pro-choice or pro-choice
or pro-life, that's like both sides of that voting block. It's
like, hey, this is our single issue. If you were to turn Israel
into a single issue, that could probably give that voting block
quite a bit of money. I just think you're probably on the wrong
side of that voting block and going to get ignored.
So I don't necessarily disagree. I think man and I I think Hutch
doesn't understand this concept in a different way. Applying
that negative pressure of like you lose my vote if you go in
this direction on this issue. He doesn't he doesn't understand
that in the same way within this the party where Pisco and Hutch
are saying we need some way to punish politicians who break with
the party and like actually screw up our agenda, right? We need
to punish people who are disruptive to the Democrats acting as
a whole, acting as a coalition. And he is totally against that,
which is interesting. Like negative consequences or expected
negative outcomes actually do change people's behavior.
And it saying that it doesn't work, I don't know, is weird sometimes,
but it seems like he's got a real aversion to saying that expected
negative outcomes will change people's behavior. you want my
coalition. I want to I want to do my my entire project in 2025
is about I want to I want to humiliate you guys as much as possible
to demonstrate how absurd your world view is. That's my project.
back bend and you you you Oh my god. At every turn, there's this
element where when someone asks you how to build the the the
right thing in the other direction away from what the Republicans
have done, you talk about how it's a 50-year project or it's
a it's going to be something in 2085 we can finally do it if
we start today. Meanwhile, the steps that would be required in
starting today and at least defining the Democratic party and
what it stands for and what it should mean and what the cost
should be to be a Democrat. Anytime somebody mentions taking
more aggressive steps towards that, you're like, "Oh, whoa, bro.
What the bro? You're going to take risks?" Like, you're so spineless.
>> Okay. Steelman my argument then. What is the cost of
your strategy if it leads to a Republican majority in Congress?
I want you to steal man my argument and tell me what the cost
is. >> You've already defined like a an unacceptable downside.
Maybe not for this guy, but he's like
>> Republican majority now from listening to Kamla not
wanting to veer away from Biden's platform. >> And what
are we saying?
What bad? >> So if if I already say so Republican majority
in Congress, that's really bad. Well, what if what you want to
do leads to a Republican majority in Congress? That would be
bad. I guess it that would kind of suck, but like it's building
to something longterm instead of just short-term compromise.
It's building to something longterm. So, at least if we lose,
then I can accept the loss as in I'm trying to build to a long-term
solution, right? That's that's going to be where Urgy is coming
from. And I don't know what Hutch has to respond to that. Let's
see.
uh authoritarianism,
uh massive cuts to social spending,
um the uh ICE becoming like the largest military police force
in public record or uh in modern history
>> yeah was from doing the >> how many dead from
how many dead from USA ID cuts. >> Well, the the you now
you suddenly care about projections. >> Excuse me. I don't
even >> going off of a number. You're going off of a projected
number. No. >> Yes, I am. Yes. >> Okay. But when
people were talking about the projected loss of life in Gaza,
you were scoffing. >> I don't care about dead people in
Gaza. You're you're a you are disgusting piece of is what you
are. >> Hold on. >> Jesus. Jesus Christ.
>> you are you are a disgusting dishonest piece of to say
that I don't care about dead people in Gaza. Go yourself. >> Go
yourself. You're disgusting is what you are.
>> Wait, what did he say precisely? >> Desktop.
You're you're affect the loss of Well, the the you now you suddenly
care about projections. Excuse me. I don't even know.
>> No, this makes the this makes the next debate make so
much sense. I listen to the next debate and he actually highlights
Hutch actually highlights how he does believe the projections
from the Gaza Ministry of Health and believes like that actually
those death numbers have been undercut. They've been undersold.
But that's very funny. Now I understand why number. You're going
off of a projected number. No. >> Yes, I am. Yes. >> Okay.
But when people were talking about the projected loss of life
in Gaza, you were scoffing. >> I don't care about dead
people in Gaza.
>> no that you in some arguments you would make you'd make
arguments based on a projected number. Probably in this Gaza
argument. I I'd imagine ogre's probably referencing something
where you said, "Oh, that's a projected number. I don't think
that's real. Like I'm not going to engage with a projected number."
Right. I'm I'm guessing it's not saying you don't care. It's
saying you wouldn't make this argument in other places. >> You're
a You are a disgusting piece of is what you are. >> Hold
on, brother. You are You are a disgusting dishonest piece of
>> Hutch is Hutch is seeing ghosts. Hutch is fighting with
a lot of people that aren't really there. >> To say that
I don't care about dead people in Gaza. Go yourself. >> Go
yourself. >> You're disgusting is what you are. >> Yes,
you did. Now you care about. >> Okay, I'm going to By the
way, guys, we've done almost two hours on Twitch. We're going
to head over to kick only for the rest of the stream. Thank you
very much for watching on Twitch. I love you guys over on Twitch,
but we're going to head to kick for the rest of the stream. Um,
real quick, I'm just going to read this comment from Matt Slice
over on Twitch. Also, in the end of the debate on Wick, Hutch
had a different meltdown in which he called history speaks disgusting
and deeply insulting. His statement that he has mere suspicion
that Hutch may not be fully honest about his position on Israel
Gaza based on Hutch's focus and rhetoric. Hutch would not let
this down, saying that he should not be able to question if he
is what he is saying is honest. Oh, interesting.
Good times. Here, I'm going to pin the uh I'm going to pin the
kick link over in the Twitch chat. All right, guys. We're heading
over to kick only for the rest of the stream. We'll see you over
there in just a moment. Okay, bye-bye. Okay, let me switch the
Twitch thing off. Boom. Boom. Boom. We're good to go. We're good
to go over here. Project. Pyance is a hell of a drug, isn't it,
though? He He's pretending to he sees ghosts at JCO. This is
all 100% intentional. There's no way. I don't know. No, it's
He's just not like really listening and engaging directly, which
kind of sucks. He's like, but this I think this is a this is
probably a byproduct of being on a show with like really really
strong debaters is that he like believes certain things and he
probably gets turned on some things and doesn't totally know
why he loses debates and then he probably has some positions
like, "Oh, we can't have anybody else in our coalition." And
I'm guessing he doesn't necessarily know where that come know
where that idea comes from. Like he doesn't he hasn't gotten
it fully like cemented. And so he's saying things and but he
doesn't he doesn't totally understand.
He's been like kind of he's his like reality's been like kind
of fractured a little bit and he's having a hard time. His brain
is too exposed with no hair. Okay. >> You said I didn't
care about projected deaths in Gaza. That's what you said. >> Did
you not scoff when the Lancet thing came out? You just you guys
casually accuse people of like wanting Palestinian people to
suffer. It's
>> It is disgusting what you guys do. >> It's your
willingness to ignore statistics when it's when it's not uh uh
helpful for you. >> I have never been mind that podcast.
Well, I'm guessing like it sucks when you go and debate against
Pisco. Pisco is very good at arguing. Pisco can convince you
of things that you like you don't uh and you don't get like all
the context he has for why he believes something. It's It's just
I'm like sympathetic to Hutch. I could see how that would happen.
>> What are you even talking about? What did I ignore in
Gaza? What are you talking about? >> The Lancet study that
said almost close to like 180 to 300,000 dead by X amount of
time that >> I saw that study. The broad consensus
is that that
broad consensus about Hold on. Hold on. The broad consensus about
this particular Lancet thing is that these numbers are wildly
inflated. Nobody seriously disputes, no serious person disputes
that the official death count is higher than what the Gaza Health
Ministry is putting out there. Most people land between like
75K and like 110K.
And I've never ignored these
>> So I have no idea what you mean where you're like, "Oh,
now you want to care about projections."
But but let's go back to what we were talking about. the USA
ID cuts. That's a relevant thing to >> Again, the projection
thing wasn't saying you're like a heartless monster who doesn't
care about dead people. It's like you discount the Lancet thing
because it's projected. It's not really well backed up. And you
brought up another number that he's kind of insinuating. It's
not well well sourced or or it's just a projected number. So,
I don't want to deal with that. >> That's
talking about the cost of giving Republicans control of government,
right? And what was that number? >> Uh I believe you keep
quoting 14 >> I keep quoting it or have you seen the same
quote? I'm sure it's out there somewhere. I've probably come
across it. >> you have. Stop. So, all of these things,
you think that those are like you think those are acceptable
costs for like >> No, I I believe it is Hutch just said
so. I believe there's literally consensus that the Gaza Health
Ministry is probably underounted the dead. Not overount, undercounted.
>> Kicking Joe um kicking Thetman out of the party. >> What?
Don't >> It doesn't have to be It doesn't have to be such
a binary.
>> When are we supposed to start? What do you What do you
mean it doesn't have to be a binary? What do you mean by that?
>> It's at a certain point it has to be more about the
decisions of of the party like the defense of the party holding
the party accountable. >> If the Democrats win if the Democrats
win control of Congress and get the presidency. So, I haven't
kept up on a lot of Israel Palestine stuff strings, but I would
just say probably if Hutch is saying it, if Hutch is saying it,
I would imagine it's probably true. I feel like Hutch is in a
very liberal space, like he's not um he's not going to I would
say he's not going to say that the Gaza Health Ministry undersshot
the numbers without pretty significant
representation, pretty significant sourcing for that that claim.
you can
>> with regards to Hutch like I do maybe not be as good
at like some abstract thinking or having arguments where yeah
like there's a lot of hypotheticals and stuff. I don't really
expect him to do ultra well there. I do expect him to do well
in terms of having like well sourced claims.
No, no, no, no, no. I So Carbide I just explained it. I do think
like his factual claims would be well sourced, but in terms of
like abstract thinking, am I going to follow some complex hypothetical?
Not necessarily so much. But I would expect him to have well
sourced claims most of the time >> outcomes over here,
right? And then if the Republicans win control of the Congress
and the presidency,
we we can reasonably expect another set of like horrible outcomes
that we just unpacked a moment ago. It is a binary choice. There
is no third party that can take control of government. It's one
or the >> Go up and [__] the bed. When the
Democrats go up and [__] the bed, when they have
a general attitude that we're going to do this with or without
you, so you better get in line, and then they fall on their face,
you don't think some measure of culpability should be put on
the Democrats themselves. >> None of that matters in the
context of this conversation.
>> No, no, it doesn't. We're talking I just asked you a
straightforward question. You're dodging it. are all the negative
externalities of the second Trump term. Do you think that that
is a uh acceptable cost to your strategy? Yes. Yes or no? >> So
if Federman gets primary, this results in Trump. >> Stop
weasling out of this. >> Stop weasling out of my hypothetical
that assumes the worst possible outcome. Stop weasling out of
it. I think Ilgbo you should have an easier time when it's like
oh if I if we just gave like Trump a majority like a super majority
by primary fetterman okay I probably wouldn't want that just
say yeah I probably wouldn't want that I think that's the easiest
thing to do yeah Trump is probably worse than whatever democratic
coalition we could have right >> question you how this
can >> no you're answer just answer the question everything
that we're seeing from Trump right >> cuz then it it all
comes down to like okay how do you know that primary fedammen
gets us like to lose Congress
Where where is that coming from? That's where you actually just
like he's got no source for that. He's got no way to explain
that. He's just making that up. >> All of it. All of it.
Is that a Is that an acceptable cost to you?
>> Is I'm trying to get you to >> I don't know how
I could be any more particular gets primared and then he loses.
A Republican gets into that spot and then in turn the majority
goes towards Trump >> and then Trump does all the things
he's already gonna do. >> Yes. Yes. >> Is that worth
it? >> Yes. That's the question. >> That's so implaus
like that's we're we're in fantasy. >> That's implausible.
What do you mean >> happened because of the campaign that
Comma ran?
>> No, no, no. You're saying that it's implausible?
I don't know. >> Just so you know, ogre boy, you you should
actually just engage with a hypothetical hearsay. Hypothetically,
if I knew that we had a majority and we would lose it via primarying
via primarying Federman, I would not want to do that. I will
give you that. I think you you give that away every time. You
shouldn't have any problem giving that away to be honest because
it gives nothing away in what you want to do, right?
Cuz you're never going to know that for sure. And you can point
to a whole bunch of reasons why having like some kind of purity
testing or having positions that you'll no longer vote for somebody
on makes sense. And there will never ever be like a certain thing
like I don't even think in this election there's a lot of reason
to believe that people virtue signaling over Israel Palestine
actually led to the Democrats losing. I don't believe that happened.
I don't believe the numbers would back that up at all. Um despite
Hassan, you know, I guess being w wishy-washy on who to vote
for, I don't think there he had like a significant outcome or
a sign significant effect on the election on the election's outcome.
Yeah. >> I don't even know. I have had no idea how you
would think that that was implausible. when the last Congress
under Joe Biden during his first term was a 50-50 Senate. So,
we know that the margins are so close that one seat could make
the difference. Why? Why would you say it's
So, the the counterpoint here would be, okay, what about blue
no matter who? Why wouldn't we just expect Pennsylvania Democrats
to be blue no matter who in their general election for the Senate,
right? Shouldn't we just be blue no matter who there? Like, why
would it matter if it was a if it was a slightly more favorable
to Israel candidate? Would that lose them the election? Really
>> because they already have the majority. >> Do
you understand what a Do you understand what a hypothetical is?
>> Do you understand what a hypothetical thought experiment
is and like the purpose of it? Do you understand that? >> You're
ogre boy. This is the only part you've really screwed up on.
You could just give him this and say, "Okay, but there's no reason
to believe that that would happen in like some hypothetical scenario,
right? One, it's like it's uh it would only be in a primary.
You're looking at a primary this candidate, right? Why? Why,
Hutch, if you're blue no matter who, why would it matter if you
have a socialist? You already said you vote socialist. Is that
not what everybody would do? >> You want your strategy
to be like bully people out of the party because they're not
ideologically aligned with you or whatever or because they support
Israel or whatever. Fine. You want that. But >> I just
want there to be a definition for what it means to be a Democrat
and right now that doesn't exist. >> Is the cost worth
it to you? Is it an acceptable cost? Yes or no? We already seeing
the cost of >> Stop dodging the question. Just answer the
question, bro. Is it an acceptable cost? Yes or no?
>> Is what an acceptable cost?
>> I All right, I'm done. He's I just, you know, that is
the last conversation. I'm hitting the black button.
Okay, now I'm getting I'm getting why he's Okay, this is the
good part. Okay, this is the good part. This is where I That
conversation wasn't the best. Okay, but it gets better now. I'm
out. Holy [__] Where's my heart meter?
>> Where's my heart meter? What happened? What did Ogre
boy even say at the end that was like that? >> I just asked
you a straightforward question. You're dodging it. Are all the
negative externalities of the second Trump turn? >> Hello.
Why do you have that avatar? Aiden, what are you doing? >> What
avatar? What are you talking about? >> You're doxing a
man. You're doxing a man right now. What are you doing? >> Is
she concerned? >> What are you doing? You're disgusting.
You're actually disgusting right now. I need Listen, I've forgiven
you, but I need your opinion on something.
>> What's that? What did you forgive me for
>> So, you you saw that Cameron F305
had a crash out today, right? It's just real quick. I don't want
to derail your
>> Listen to the He bleeps a word on his end while talking
about me. >> I want your honest assessment of what you
think he said. >> It's like real quick.
>> Tell me I'm crazy. Sent it.
I can see the title. What? >> But what? >> Listen.
Look at the Look at the way his mouth. It's one syllable. It's
one continuous word. Whatever he said. >> Oh, I see. I
see. I see. I see. I see. I see. I see. Hold on. So, it's not
even questionable here. The question is not did he say something
that means person? The question is what word did he use to describe
this shifty person? We all know Aiden, right? >> Yeah.
I well I mean I I'm questioning if he said either at all but
like I can't think of I've thought of every other word that could
go in its place in that context and Jew is just >> first
of all we have do we have his stream because it's already like
really low quality. Oh, I'll go up to 720p cuz I need to actually
zoom in and see his >> I need to zoom in see his face as
this comes up. Okay, >> there you go. You've revealed yourself.
Okay, you're okay. >> Okay, hold on. Debated. You can go
debate my goddamn sphincter. That guy is a debate. And a shifty
>> shifty. Shifty. I think shifty 100%. Ooh. Ooh. Ooh.
I see that. I see his lips go. Ooh.
>> I I saw it and I I needed I needed a person to say it
so it didn't look like I was being like neurotic.
>> Well, hold on. I I think Sorry. There's a there's an
argument that he said
with a 5% chance he said this word. He definitely did not say
this word. >> Oh, no. Of course not. I disagree with that.
Okay. >> Yeah, that's No, 100%. I think he said that, but
>> Okay, hold on. >> Just to be clear, another one
that could be there is shifty dude. And those might look the
same. Let's watch again. >> Why would he bleep that, though?
>> Uh, well, do you know that he bleeped
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. He He did a live sensor. He has a button.
Yes.
>> Well, then he is he is joking that he's saying there,
right? He could have said, "Dude, I don't know. Oh, this is one
of those things where it's like >> you can go debate my
goddamn sphincter. That guy is dead >> and a shifty.
>> The the thing is though, if
the song had a clip like this, I you know me, you know I don't
give like a if someone if someone says some like
>> to me or whatever the >> Okay, but you are a shifty
Jew. >> You're the most anti-semitic person I've ever met
and I still talk to you, right? >> I'm not anti-Semitic.
You are You are shifty. They're not related. You you you sent
me a copy of mine comp for my
>> Okay. Um well that's because you asked for it. It's
not my fault you're
>> Okay. Victim blaming much.
But essentially
like if Assan had a clip like this there would be absolutely
no charitability here. Like he would be branded an anti-semite.
Like this is just crazy to me. This is this is their guy. That's
their guy. >> Yeah. But you can't soy about it. You can't
soy about it. That's the problem cuz it's not really something
you be that mad about, right? >> I'm offended by the hypocrisy.
I'm not offended of what he said. I'm offended by the fact that
these people are going to like throw the biggest monthsl long
fit about like anti-semitism
um like interpreting it everywhere, >> but they have like
clips like this.
>> Well, I think so. The issue what you're going to run
into is they're going to say, "Yeah, but like sincerely, we've
seen nothing in this guy's content. We've seen nothing from this
guy overall that shows us that he has any concerning attitudes
towards, but person we've seen like months and months of content
where we've seen lots of like potentially anti-semitic acts or
feelings or or behaviors."
That's what their argument is going to be, right? So that while
he and also you have your own your own humor, your own friend
group who will like say things like this without a lot of hate
in it. So, like there's there's reasons for him to think probably
that you wouldn't have a problem with this if he's familiar with
you. And then there's >> No, you don't know. Wait, you
don't know the context?
>> You don't know the context. >> Well, the the context
is somebody asked to debate you. >> We hate each other.
>> It's not friendly at all. Like, he despises me. >> Sure.
It depends on how aware of your stuff he is. I'm just saying
that like like I feel like I've probably said this to you. We
don't hate each other. I don't have like hate in my heart when
I say it to you, but like I'm sure Kleman or somebody else would
have said it to you, too. And I don't know. I understand where
you're coming from that it feels it smacks a little bit of hypocrisy,
but I think um yeah, it sucks.
>> Yeah. I don't know, dude. I don't know. I mean, if we're
going to back if we're going to have some consistency here, uh
someone needs to get me in contact with Dan Saltman. We need
to rally the boys uh with the ADL and we need to go in and get
this kid channel taken down everywhere. All right. This is ridiculous.
Blatant anti-semitism.
>> You can message Dan and say you can message Dan right
now and say, "Hey, this guy guy's anti-semitic
entire family." Dan,
>> I totally dis.
>> Okay, let's >> Dan's running for me. He promised
me an interview uh and he totally from it. So, I'm not going
to get anywhere with him. >> yeah, he doesn't like self-hating.
>> Hard to blame him. >> Yeah, maybe I need to just
start doing the the self love lang
for the state of Israel. Okay. >> So true. So true. >> All
right. Bye-bye. Damn. All right. Cool. Back to this guy. Okay.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
>> Black Irish. Thank you for the 17 months. Let's go.
term. Do you think that that is a acceptable cost to your strategy?
Yes. Yes. Or >> Okay. So, let's back it up a little bit
here cuz it's it's going to be, hey, if we lose people because
of the primary stuff, is that acceptable cost? >> I think
some measure of culpability should be put on the Democrats >> None
of that matters in the context of this conversation. >> It
matters. >> No, no, it doesn't. We're talking I just asked
you a straightforward question. You're dodging it. or all the
negative externalities of the second Trump term. Do you think
that that is a uh acceptable cost to your strategy? Yes. Yes
or no? >> So if Federman gets primary, this results in
Trump. >> Stop weasling out.
>> Wait, he's actually clarifying
>> of this question. >> You how this connects. >> No,
you're
>> That was just him clarifying. >> Just answer the
question. Everything that we're seeing from Trump right now,
all of it. All of it. Is that a Is that an acceptable cost to
you
>> is I'm trying to get you to >> I don't know how
I could be any more
>> I don't know why Hutch is like just debate for no reason.
>> It doesn't look good when you listen. You You want to
fight somebody and you're like getting heated and you start being
a debate. That's one thing. But if somebody's like trying to
like just talk to you and you're going debate mode, it's not
not the best all the time. Okay. and then he loses. A Republican
gets into that spot >> and then in turn the majority goes
towards Trump >> and then Trump does all the things he's
already going to do.
>> Is that worth it? >> Yes, that's the question.
>> That's so implaus Like that's we're we're in fantasy.
>> That's implausible.
>> What do you mean that's >> happened because of
the campaign that Kler ran?
>> No, no, no. You're saying that it's implausible?
I don't know. I don't even know. I have had no idea how you would
think that that was implausible when the last Congress under
>> cuz it was 50/50 back then. >> Joe Biden, >> again,
I think your response to this is, "Well, I thought all the liberals
were going to be blue no matter who. Why would why would a primary
loss affect how Pennsylvania turns out?" >> During his
first term was a >> The answer there is the centrist voters.
You can't lose the centrist. There are no far-left centrist voters.
And then Ogre Boy has to respond. Yeah, but there have to be
or else our we'll never ever get policy that reflects our values.
Unfortunately, that is game theoretically the only way you actually
get it right is by willing to walk away and hurt yourself and
willing be being like we are not like negotiating over >> 50-50
Senate. So we know that the Mardman are so close that one seat
could make the difference. Why why would you say it's implausible?
>> Because they already have the majority. >> Do
you understand what a Do you understand what a hypothetical is?
>> Do you understand what a hypothetical thought experiment
is and like the purpose of it? Do you understand that? You want
your strategy to be like bully people out of the party because
they're not ideologically aligned with you or whatever or because
they support Israel or whatever. Fine. You want that. But >> I
just want there to be a definition for what it means to be a
Democrat and right now that doesn't exist. >> Is the cost
worth it to you? Is it an >> Is Ogre boy an accelerationist?
Why doesn't he acknowledge the consequence of what he wants?
Wait, that's not the consequence of what he wants necessarily?
Primarying John Fetman does not mean that the Democrats lose
a majority. That's not what he's saying. Hutch is asking if that
were the consequence, would you still want to do it? And to that
he should answer no,
right? But there are reasons why you would do it. I think
uh like basically it's no because I want to build something longterm
that like hey I want something I can believe in. I want like
something that can generate enthusiasm. There like a lot of ways
he would argue this but the answer probably should be yes in
the short term. An >> acceptable cost yes or no. We already
seeing the cost. >> Stop dodging the >> now. Now
you are dodging probably. >> Question. Just answer the
question, bro. Is it an acceptable cost? >> Yes or no?
>> Is what an acceptable cost?
>> I All right, I'm done.
Um, I think Ogre Boy was dodging a little bit at the end, but
I think Hutch Hutch raised the temperature for no reason. I don't
I don't even know why. Ogre boy is trying to be like pretty calm,
and he raised the temperature a lot. Hutch was right, I would
say, right at the end. Right at the very end, Hutch probably
has a reason to be mad. But for a lot of it, he was raising the
temperature for no reason. For no reason. Yes. For a lot of it,
be very vivic. Hutch had a very like heated tone for not a lot
of reason. At the end, he does have reason to be heated.
At the end, I think Ogre Boy is kind of with him. Okay. But for
a lot of it where the tone got increased, got ramped up, I think
I think that is Hutch. That is on Hutch. For a lot of it at the
beginning, he misinterpreted that thing about caring about projections
and went the off thinking it was an attack. I think yeah that
that happened but he was also before that about I don't want
you in my coalition. I don't want you anywhere near my coalition.
Is Canada system better for dealing with the political deadlock
in the US? Which do you like more? No, not really. Um there's
no deadlock here, but I I don't think it's like a better system.
I think it leads to like strategic voting. It's it ends up like
essentially being a two-party system without three um chambers
of government, right? It's just got two chambers. Just give me
one second. I'll be right back. He's I just you know that is
the last conversation I'm hitting the block button. I'm out.
Holy sh Where's my heart meter? Talk about punching down. Jesus
Christ.
I am so boiling with rage right now, you guys. The heart rate.
Let's take a look. I'm guessing 105. Wait, it's not working.
Hold on. There we go. Why isn't that working? >> We're
checking Hutch's pulse. Let's go. >> I can't get it to
work. Hold on. >> What's How's he doing? >> Oh, there
it goes. There we go. That's not right. It said 70. There's no
way. There's no way. It's like I'm saying it's like 110 105.
>> Is he bald by choice? I believe he had he has like some
hair with
something. >> These the these people are so profoundly
unserious people. I you know >> so profoundly unserious
people. >> That's my project. Like my entire project right
now is like attacking that this this attitude about like politics.
It's so stupid. It is so prolific. >> It's like the idea
of the single issue voter. And you could be against the idea
of the singleisssue voter, but unfortunately the the single issue
voters have like the most power. That's the that's the issue.
How do you come up with a system where single issue voters like
lose a lot of their power, but
you maintain like a solid democracy? Cuz people who are single
issue voters, they're they're really good at getting that single
issue advocated for. In these spaces, they have these commonly
accepted things that are just completely inongruent with reality
or practical considerations or any semblance of
>> We didn't even get to the AOC thing. >> That is
kind of true.
>> So, I'll just explain why. There was nothing wrong with
AOC's vote. The the amendment to AO that AOC voted against
failed by like 400 plus votes. There were only six people, I
think, in the entire Congress that voted to strip funding for
Israel's uh Iron Dome Missile Defense System. It was a doomed
bill. Everybody knew it was a doomed bill. It doesn't matter.
It doesn't mean anything.
The bill doesn't do it didn't it wasn't going to stop anything.
These lefties that are her for taking this vote are acting like
she was like the deciding vote. And if she would have only voted
yes, you know, we would have like dismantled Israel's defense
systems. It didn't matter. It didn't matter. To be fair to Hutch,
Ogre Boy said it would be punching down to talk to Hutch. To
say Hutch was unreasonable to come in the way he did is kind
of unfair. Be punching down to talk to Hutch. Wait, I thought
Hutch said that to Ogre Boy. Wait, I didn't think I thought I
didn't think the punching down comment was in that context. Hold
on. I have a transcript here yet? I don't. Would I have a on
Twitter or? Yeah, I actually Hold on. Let me see if we got We
might have a transcript here by now. >> Wasn't going to
stop it. >> We got a transcript yet. Come on. Nope. No
transcript. OG boy said it to Hutch. Well, Hutch said it back
to Ogre Boy in this that I I think I'd be punching down talking
to you, right? Or did he say it's a w It'd be a waste of my time
talking to you. He got really like hottie and and like smug at
one point. He did say it back. Hold on. I think Are we Maybe
I just missed Ogre Boy saying it to him. I didn't think he was
saying he would be punching down talking to him, but maybe he
did. Give me a second. You roll it back.
>> I'm a content creator. >> For a list that is more
performative than anything else with the fullest extent that
we possibly could. >> See if we can find this. >> So,
you're just chasing catharsis. This little like Twitter video
serves your own like ego. >> It was to on Dan Saltman and
it went
>> Well, why don't we finish the >> Hutch is referring
to Ogre Boy talking on Twitter, I think. Okay. All right. At
the start of the conver >> I mean you you conversation
problems
>> we'll wait for we'll wait for it. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. >> So you couldn't make it through the video. You
kept reseting it several times in the course of which we're talking
on and on about uh how you donate to Liz Cheney and you missed
the point of of her video altogether with what she was trying
to say. >> No, it sounds like you did. No, no, no. It sounds
like you did by the way. >> Enlighten me >> because
the point of her video was that the way the Democrats are going
to win is through coalition building. It cuts both ways. >> I'll
just You know what? We'll we'll come back back to this another
time when there's a what do you call it? like a time stamp or
something when there's a transcript. I don't want to go through
this whole thing like right now just to look for that. It's fine
if if that was it's not really uh consequential to be honest
in how we interpret this. But I will say >> and if she
if she would have voted yes for that she obviously I think has
aspir sorry I got to skip back to the end of this where we get
uh Hutch going and getting his heart meter. >> Okay, let's
uh >> this is close enough for me. >> How did I do
that? I'm going to steer the conversation to one about AOC and
we can so she votes yes to strip funding for Israel's Meta Reaper.
Did I not say thank you? Oh, I'm sorry buddy. Rashid Talibar
and Al Green and one other progressive house. They voted no,
but they're not as high profile as AOC. It's not clear to me
that any of those people want to advance in their careers and
so they get to do >> All I'm looking for right now is once
he uh I guess maybe it's once he goes into the um the debate,
the next debate >> popular with constituents or be rooting
for her. Okay, let's uh >> he got he got rattled by this
and he goes into the Wick debate. He actually keeps talking about
it. Okay. She better know on the Oh, I'm sorry. She better know
on the final bill, which
How are you, by the way? >> Just fully triggered right
now. Oneonone conversation between speaks. So, >> Oh, Jesus
Christ. I thought this was a >> All right. Hold on. Let
me Let me Let me turn on my camera. >> Okay. Well, he's
not here yet. Hopefully, he gets here soon. >> Yeah, it's
him the other day. >> He's just like Yeah, he's like just
tweaking. He's tweaking.
>> How are you, by the way? >> Just fully triggered
right now. I just had a really stupid debate um about a similar
topic. How are you doing? >> One with Straight Raid. I
saw that one >> No, I was chatting with Ogre Boy.
>> Okay, I know who that guy is. >> You're familiar
with his game. >> I I am familiar with Ogre Boy. >> His
style of engagement. Um sorry you had to deal with that. Let
me send >> It's fine. I did it to myself. >> Hopefully
this one this will go better and this will be a little bit better
of a of a conversation. Um >> no, I've had a conversation
with him before and it was fine. It was civil. It didn't get
crazy. It was fine. Okay. >> This could have been civil.
>> Just going to link this time stamp here. Which one is
this? Is this the to the very beginning here? >> Yeah.
I see you've been um >> Oh, right here.
>> There we go. >> Oh, I I talk my I talk my >> You
said you said recently that you feel bad for me and that like
by debating me it would be punching down. What do you mean by
>> Oh, I see. He said it on Twitter. >> You were
on a really wild tear on Friday. No. >> Which tear? You
don't uh towards the end of this the thing that I screenshotted
that that got your attention in the first place. >> I don't
even put up the uh what >> I don't I don't even remember.
>> I mean that kind of speaks to it. Don't you think? The
Twitter video towards the end. What's the uh Sarah what? Sarah
McBride. What's what's her name? >> Sarah Mc Yeah. Rep.
Sarah McBride. Yeah. >> Right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> So,
you couldn't make it through the video. You kept resetting it
several times and in the course of which you were talking on
and on about uh how you would donate to >> Okay. All right.
I see. Yeah, it's the the Twitter commentary. Okay. The but I
would say for Hutch, the punching down on you thing makes uh
it's way less, you know, egotistical or weird now. I'd say it
looks way better in in that light. Okay. In that light, it looks
a little better. It's not quite so bad. That's mostly how we
see it. Okay. All right. Anyway, we're moving forward now. Now
I